Not long ago, the guy who headed the youth group at Covenant Presbyterian Church decided to hold a debate. Half the kids in the youth group had to argue for Christianity. Half the kids had to make the case that Christianity was all made up, a fairy tale. And the Christians lost.
不久前，圣约长老会青年团契的负责人决定举办一场辩论。青年团契里一半的孩子必须为基督教辩护，另一半孩子则要论证基督教全是虚构的，只是一个童话故事。结果，基督教派输了。
And I think the number one reason why is because they tried to just come at it with a lot of facts.
我认为最主要的原因是，他们试图仅凭大量事实来赢得辩论。
Dan Adamson is the youth leader.
丹·亚当森是青年团契的领袖。
And it was amazing to watch these-- the ones that were debating Christianity said, Jesus is real. There's people that found him, and there's proof on this, and they-- evidence.
看着这些孩子真是令人惊叹——那些为基督教辩护的孩子说，耶稣是真实存在的。有人找到了他，这有证据，他们有证据。
Archaeological records.
考古记录。
Archaeological records. And what was so awesome, by the non-Christian debate team, is they said, fine. We totally acknowledge that Jesus is real. But so was Mohammed. So was Buddha. So was this. And the Christians were like, yeah, but Jesus is real. And he died on the cross and he rose again. And the non-Christians came back and said, well, there's people that believe that. But there's also people that believe Mohammed was this. And what I wish the Christians would have done, would have bee said, here am I. I believe God is real because He's changed my life. And put myself on the witness stand and say, here's what I was before God and here's who I am now.
考古记录。非基督教辩论队最棒的地方在于，他们说，好吧，我们完全承认耶稣是真实存在的。但穆罕默德也是，佛陀也是，这些人都是。而基督徒们则说，是的，但耶稣是真实的，他死在十字架上，然后复活了。非基督徒反驳道，确实有人相信这一点，但也有人相信穆罕默德是这样的。我希望基督徒当时能做的是站出来说，我在这里，我相信上帝是真实的，因为他改变了我的生命。将自己放在见证人的位置上，说出我在上帝面前过去是什么样，现在又是什么样。
The problem is, for the teenagers in this youth group, the phrase, here's who I was before I found God, it has no meaning. They all come from families that discuss the Bible at dinner. They go to church every Sunday. They come from the kind of homes where all the kids can tell you how many swears are in the movie Titanic, because every TV show and film is pre-screened.
问题在于，对于这个青年团契的青少年来说，“我在找到上帝之前是什么样”这句话毫无意义。他们都来自在晚餐时讨论圣经的家庭。他们每周日都去教堂。他们来自那种所有孩子都能告诉你电影《泰坦尼克号》里有多少句脏话的家庭，因为所有的电视节目和电影都是经过预先筛选的。
I have kids that are willing to serve, kids that know the Bible, kids that know their theology. This is the only truth they've known. They've been told from the very beginning God loves them, God has a plan for them. Jesus is their Savior. They've been singing "Jesus Loves Me" since they've been five years old.
我有一些乐于奉献的孩子，他们了解圣经，了解神学。这是他们所知的唯一真理。他们从一开始就被告知上帝爱他们，上帝为他们有计划，耶稣是他们的救主。他们五岁起就在唱《耶稣爱我》。
It's time for them to develop their own faith, not just to parrot back what their parents say. Dan says this. Most of the parents say it. They need to question what they've learned and come to their own conclusions. If they don't do it now, Dan says, they'll do it later, without parents and a youth pastor to nudge them toward God. So Dan decided to take them to West Virginia. It will be a mission trip, the youth group's first mission trip. They'd have to help poor people. They'd have to testify about God's word to strangers. It would be hard, and hardship can make you turn to God. And they'd see the kind of things that make people engage serious questions about their faith.
现在是时候让他们发展出自己的信仰，而不是仅仅鹦鹉学舌般地重复父母的话。丹这么说，大多数父母也这么说。他们需要质疑自己所学的东西，并得出自己的结论。丹说，如果他们现在不这么做，以后也会做，到时候就没有父母和青年牧师引导他们走向上帝了。于是丹决定带他们去西弗吉尼亚州。这将是一次宣教之旅，是青年团契的第一次宣教之旅。他们将不得不帮助穷人，不得不向陌生人见证上帝的话语。这会很艰难，而苦难能让人转向上帝。他们会看到那些促使人们深入思考信仰的问题。
If they begin doubting because they look in this world and they see hard lives in West Virginia, they see people that are hurting, and they see this and they look up and they think, why would God allow that to happen? That's like an example of I think where I'd start seeing more growth.
如果他们开始怀疑，因为他们观察这个世界，看到了西弗吉尼亚州艰难的生活，看到了受伤的人，他们看着上面想，为什么上帝允许这种事发生？我想这就是我开始看到更多成长的地方。
So that was the plan. Now, let's meet some of the teenagers. Kelly Hoover's age 14, long brown hair, braces, lip gloss. Kelly's outgoing and bright and she's somebody capable of saying exactly what is on her mind.
这就是计划。现在，来认识一下这些青少年吧。凯莉·胡佛14岁，留着长长的棕色头发，戴着牙套，涂着唇彩。凯莉性格开朗、聪明，是一个能准确表达自己想法的人。
Well, I really want to meet the kids there and just-- because I mean, I don't want to sound snotty or anything but-- I'm more privileged than most people. I mean, I live in a big house. I have a pool. And I don't really see kids a lot who don't have as much as I do. And I really just want to see what it's like, and how living with them is. And I really just want to teach them about Jesus, because I don't know how I could live without Him. And sometimes I think how blessed I was to be born in such a family.
嗯，我真的很想去见那里的孩子们，因为——我的意思是，我不想听起来很势利或者怎么样——但我比大多数人幸运。我的意思是，我住在大房子里，我有游泳池。我不太常看到像我这样拥有不多东西的孩子。我真的很想看看那是什么样子，和他们住在一起是什么感觉。我真的只想教他们认识耶稣，因为我不知道没有他我该怎么活。有时候我想，出生在这样的家庭是多么有福。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, A Teenager's Guide to God, the story of five adults, 11 kids, and six days in West Virginia. Of adults trying to mold the faith of teenagers and things not working out quite as planned.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目是《青少年上帝指南》，讲述了5名成年人、11名孩子在西弗吉尼亚州六天的故事。讲述成年人试图塑造青少年的信仰，以及事情并没有完全按计划进行的过程。
It's an odd fact of religious life in America that in this country founded by Christians, in which a majority of people say they believe in God and identify themselves as Christians, that so many religious Christians feel that they are an oppressed minority. They say the media doesn't share their values, that secular institutions undermine their beliefs. And the job of raising Christian children, they'll tell you, is like trying to do God's work from behind enemy lines.
在美国宗教生活中，有一个奇怪的事实：在这个由基督徒建立、大多数人声称相信上帝并自认为是基督徒的国家里，许多虔诚的基督徒却感到自己是被压迫的少数群体。他们说媒体不认同他们的价值观，世俗机构破坏了他们的信仰。他们会告诉你，抚养基督徒子女的工作就像是在敌后开展上帝的工作。
Today we are devoting our entire program to the kids that they're struggling to bring up. This American Life producer Susan Burton and I spent a week this August recording these teenagers, day and night, throughout their mission trip. And we bring you this portrait of what it means to be a Christian teenager in America, for some kids anyway, around the turn of the millennium. Stay with us.
今天，我们整个节目都献给他们努力抚养的这些孩子。《美国生活》制片人苏珊·伯顿和我今年八月花了一周时间，昼夜不停地记录了这些青少年在宣教之旅中的表现。我们为您呈现这些千禧年之交的基督徒青少年（至少是部分孩子）的生活画像。请继续收听。
Act One, Exodus. The youth group is part of Covenant Presbyterian Church here in Chicago, a city church with lots of members who live out in the suburbs. A number of their parents were founding members of the church, less than two decades ago. These teenagers are 13 to 17. They all grew up attending Christian schools or homeschools. Our trip began with a 14-hour drive in two rented vans to West Virginia.
第一幕，出埃及。这个青年团契隶属于芝加哥的圣约长老会教堂，这是一座有许多成员居住在郊区的城市教堂。他们的许多父母不到二十年前就是教堂的创始成员。这些青少年年龄在13到17岁之间。他们都在基督教学校或在家接受教育中长大。我们的旅程始于乘坐两辆租来的面包车前往西弗吉尼亚州，车程14小时。
Can we hear LFO? Because Ira has never heard it. Ira, have you heard the summer girls song? Summertime girls? Oh, it's so funny. Where's my bag?
我们可以听LFO的歌吗？因为艾拉从来没听过。艾拉，你听过那首夏日女孩歌吗？夏日女孩？哦，太有趣了。我的包在哪？
We were barely in the van 10 minutes when Marisa and Kelly asked Dan to play the song that became the unofficial theme song to our trip. It wasn't by Jars of Clay or dc Talk or any of the other Christian pop bands whose CDs we'd brought. It was a rap song, by a white, one-hit wonder boy band called LFO. Everybody spent the ride down trying to memorize the lyrics.
我们上车还没十分钟，玛丽莎和凯莉就要求丹播放那首成为我们旅程非官方主题曲的歌。那不是Jars of Clay或dc Talk，也不是我们带的任何其他基督教流行乐队的作品。这是一首说唱歌曲，由一个只有一首热门单曲的白人男子组合LFO演唱。大家在旅途中都在努力背诵歌词。
[MUSIC - "SUMMER GIRLS" BY LFO]
[音乐 - LFO的《SUMMER GIRLS》]
Ah! I missed it! I missed the Billy Shakespeare-- that's the-- I wait. Sonnets! OK, OK, OK -- start it over. I  got it. So it's after the Larry Bird. What does he say?
啊！我错过了！我错过了比利·莎士比亚——那是——等一下。十四行诗！好了，好了，好了——重新开始。我记住了。是在拉里·伯德之后。他说什么？
Dan is 29, married, with a new baby. But in the van, he's more like a counselor adored by his campers than youth pastor. The girls strain their necks and try to meet his eyes in the rear-view mirror as they talk, asking what he and one of the other leaders, Dave, were like back in college together at the evocatively named Moody Bible Institute. Teasing him about the songs he likes, which, as far as they're concerned, are impossibly old-- 10, maybe 15 years. He tries just as hard as anybody to learn the words to "Summer Girls."
丹29岁，已婚，有一个新生儿。但在车里，他更像是一个被露营者崇拜的辅导员，而不是青年牧师。女孩们伸长脖子，在交谈时试图在后视镜里与他目光接触，问他和另一位领袖戴夫在那些名字引人注目的穆迪圣经学院读大学时是什么样子。取笑他喜欢的歌曲，对她们来说，那些歌已经老得不可思议了——大概有10年、15年了。他像其他人一样努力学习《Summer Girls》的歌词。
[SINGING] Macaulay Culkin was home alone.
[演唱] 麦考利·卡尔金独自在家。
[MUSIC - "SUMMER GIRLS" BY LFO]
[音乐 - LFO的《SUMMER GIRLS》]
[SINGING] --was Alex P. Keaton.
[演唱] ——是亚历克斯·P·基顿。
What is that from?
那出自哪里？
You know, Family Ties?
你知道，《成长的烦恼》？
Oh, I never watched that show.
哦，我从没看过那个节目。
I did. Sometimes. And Mallory, and what was that other girl's name?
我看过。有时。还有马洛里，那个女孩叫什么名字？
That's too '80s for me, Arden says, I couldn't watch it. These girls are the children that the Christian right has in mind when it holds press conferences on what's at stake in America's culture war. They are cannon fodder in that war. Just a few years before they were born, a child psychologist named Dr. James Dobson founded a group called Focus on the Family. It is an enormous religious organization based in Colorado Springs.
“那对我来说太八十年代了，”阿登说，“我看不下去。”这些女孩正是基督教右翼在就美国文化战争利害关系举行新闻发布会时所考虑的对象。她们是那场战争中的炮灰。在她们出生前几年，一位名叫詹姆斯·多布森博士的儿童心理学家创立了一个名为“爱家协会”的组织。这是一个总部位于科罗拉多斯普林斯的庞大宗教组织。
Dobson's genius is that he offers exhaustive, concrete advice on everything from child discipline to movie-going to a generation of parents who are trying to raise their kids in a new way, or rather, in a very old way. As part of that, Dobson has built an entire superstructure to shield young people from Hollywood, from rap music, from the WB. Focus on the Family publishes an ongoing encyclopedic guide which evaluates pop culture from a Christian perspective for parents. In addition, they've created an empire of Christian pop of their own-- original radio dramas and children's videos, books, websites, and several magazines.
多布森的天才之处在于，他为那些试图以新方式——或者说，以非常古老的方式——抚养孩子的父母们提供了从儿童纪律到观看电影等各方面的详尽、具体的建议。作为其中的一部分，多布森建立了一整套上层建筑，旨在保护年轻人免受好莱坞、说唱音乐和WB电视台的影响。“爱家协会”出版了一份持续更新的百科全书式指南，从基督徒的角度为父母评估流行文化。此外，他们还建立了一个属于自己的基督教流行文化帝国——原创广播剧和儿童视频、书籍、网站以及几本杂志。
It is a remarkably effective social experiment. These teenagers don't even fight with their parents about what they can watch and listen to. At this point, they generally agree that certain films and shows are bad for them. And if you ask them about any of the TV shows targeted at and beloved by so many of their 14- and 15-year-old peers-- Dawson's, Buffy, Felicity-- you can hear their parents' voices and Dr. Dobson's voice in their replies.
这是一项非常有效的社会实验。这些青少年甚至不会因为能看什么、听什么而与父母争吵。在这一点上，他们通常认为某些电影和节目对他们有害。如果你问他们关于许多14、15岁同龄人喜爱并追捧的电视节目（如《道森的青春》、《吸血鬼猎人巴菲》、《费莉希蒂》）的看法，你会从他们的回答中听到父母和多布森博士的声音。
You feel really guilty walking away, that you just totally perverted your mind with all this stuff.
你走开时会感到非常内疚，觉得你完全用这些东西扭曲了自己的思想。
It's so unrealistic and sick. The fact that a boy is sleeping with his teacher, and he's like 15 years old. I mean, and these people are supposed to be 15 and 16 years old. And if that was how my life was, I would be dead right now. Because that's just ridiculous. Everybody is jumping in bed with everyone else and is all switching. I mean, by the middle of the series, I was hearing through rumors that so-and-so, who had been with the teacher, is now with this girl, who was actually on depressants. I mean, I have no idea what's going on.
这太不现实而且病态了。一个男孩竟然和他的老师睡觉，他才15岁。我的意思是，这些人应该才15、16岁。如果我的生活是那样，我现在肯定已经死了。因为那太荒谬了。每个人都和别人上床，又不停地交换。我的意思是，在剧集进行到一半时，我听到传言说，和老师在一起的那个人现在又和那个吃抗抑郁药的女孩在一起。我完全不知道在发生什么。
It's Andie, one of the supposed non-viewers pipes up from the back. What's so interesting about these girls is the odd mix of Christian and secular pop in their lives. Despite their Christian schools, despite their carefully monitored TV viewing, they do not seem out of touch. They're not un-hip. And here is the most important thing that they would want you to know about them. They like being Christians. This is Lauren.
“是安迪，”其中一个所谓的“非观众”在后面插嘴说。这些女孩最有趣的地方在于，她们生活中基督教和世俗流行文化的奇怪结合。尽管有基督教学校，尽管有严加监视的电视观看习惯，她们看起来并不与世隔绝。她们并不落伍。而这是她们最想让你了解的一点：她们喜欢成为基督徒。这是劳伦。
It's hard for people to understand that we really enjoy this religion. That us, as teenagers, who are the ones who are out to have fun and whatever, that this is actually something that means something to us, and that we are having fun doing this.
人们很难理解我们真的很享受这种宗教。我们作为青少年，那些追求乐趣的人，这实际上对我们意义重大，而且我们乐在其中。
As they've gotten older, some of them have taken more steps, carefully measured steps, into the secular world. Ruth and Jessica and Anna go to a public high school, and it isn't that kids at the school are hostile to Christianity, as they were, Dan says, when he was a teenager. These days, the attitude at the school is, if Christianity is your thing, that's fine, just so long as you don't push it onto other people. Of all the teenagers in the youth group, the one struggling the most with how to live as a religious person in the secular world is one of the two boys on the trip, Joel.
随着年龄的增长，她们中的一些人已经谨慎地迈出了走向世俗世界的步伐。露丝、杰西卡和安娜在公立高中上学，这并不是说学校里的孩子像丹年轻时那样对基督教有敌意。现在，学校里的态度是：如果基督教是你的兴趣所在，那没问题，只要你不把它强加给别人就行。在青年团契的所有青少年中，在世俗世界中如何以宗教人士身份生活而感到最挣扎的人，是这次旅行中仅有的两名男孩之一——乔尔。
I've had my share of dealings with kids who've been at public school, and I just don't really like what I see.
我处理过不少公立学校孩子的事，我真的不喜欢我所看到的。
Joel's 13 and probably the most sheltered person in the group. His mother's always homeschooled him because, he says, she feels that Christian schools only teach Christian values during Bible class. She feels it should be enunciated in all the subjects. Joel's getting out more and more. Just this summer, he spent three weeks away from home for the first time in his life. And it was with non-Christian kids on a soccer trip to England.
乔尔13岁，可能是团契里最受保护的孩子。他母亲一直让他接受在家教育，因为他说，她觉得基督教学校只在圣经课上教基督教价值观。她认为应该在所有科目中都体现出来。乔尔出门的机会越来越多。就在今年夏天，他第一次离家三周，是和非基督徒孩子一起去英格兰进行足球旅行。
I don't know. I mean, I learned a lot of stories and jokes and stuff. But they were all really nasty and unrepeatable, if that gives you an idea of, you know, what kids learn in public schools. And it's like, the boys are always talking about sex or things that have to do with sex. And you know, I mean, at this age, yeah, I'm starting to think about that, but still I don't like talking about it.
我不知道。我的意思是，我学了很多故事、笑话之类的东西。但它们都非常肮脏且不堪入耳，如果你能想象公立学校的孩子学到了什么的话。就像，男孩们总是谈论性或者与性有关的事情。你知道，我的意思是，在这个年纪，是的，我开始思考这个问题，但我还是不喜欢谈论它。
A typical joke? The only one that I could drag out of him involved a boy, a girl having her period, a car late at night, a policeman, and a pizza. Believe me, you don't want to know.
典型的笑话？我唯一能从他那里问出来的涉及一个男孩、一个生理期的女孩、一辆深夜的车、一个警察和一个披萨。相信我，你不会想知道的。
It was just incredible. I mean, they were-- it's just, they were the most-- and they didn't-- but--
真是太不可思议了。我的意思是，他们是——只是，他们是……而且他们没有——但是——
He is literally at a loss for words.
他真的到了无话可说的地步。
And then some of the guys just got a kick out of acting like they were gay or something. On the bus ride they found out that that annoyed me, so they did that the rest of the trip. Acting like they were after me, if you know what I mean. They would say stuff in kind of an exaggerated, effeminate kind of accent. There was one guy who would always wink at me. And I'm like, Matt, knock it off. And he's like, oh, come on. You know you want it. And I'm like, no, I don't.
然后一些家伙竟然以此为乐，假装自己是同性恋什么的。在公交车上，他们发现这让我很烦，于是他们就在旅程剩下的时间里一直那样做。假装他们在追求我，如果你明白我的意思。他们会用一种夸张的、女性化的口音说些话。有个家伙总是对我眨眼。我说，马特，停下来。他说，哦，得了吧，你知道你想要的。我说，不，我才不想要。
Up until this point, you've been homeschooled. You haven't been around other kids. And so, was this literally the first time this had happened to you?
到目前为止，你一直接受在家教育。你没怎么接触过其他孩子。那么，这真的是第一次发生这种事吗？
Yes.
是的。
Compared with all the other kids on the trip, Joel's family is much more fundamentalist in the way that it incorporates the Bible into their daily lives. Whatever benefits he gets from that, the kids whose parents try to balance secular and Christian influences all seem way more at ease in themselves and in the world.
与其他参加旅行的孩子相比，乔尔的家庭在将圣经融入日常生活方面要原教旨主义得多。无论他从中得到什么好处，那些试图平衡世俗和基督教影响的父母的孩子，看起来在自我和世界中要自在得多。
[MUSIC - "SUMMER GIRLS" BY LFO]
[音乐 - LFO的《SUMMER GIRLS》]
[SINGING] I like girls that wear Abercrombie and Fitch. I'd take her if I had one wish.
[演唱] 我喜欢穿Abercrombie and Fitch的女孩。如果有一个愿望，我会带走她。
For the rest of the drive, the girls sing the LFO song every few hours. They ruffle through the pages of Teen People , read stories out loud to each other, close the magazine in their laps, flip it over and begin again. By the time we arrive in West Virginia, this is the first accomplishment of the trip. Nearly everybody has memorized all the words.
在剩余的旅途中，女孩们每隔几个小时就会唱一次LFO的那首歌。她们翻阅《Teen People》杂志，大声读故事给彼此听，把杂志合上放在腿上，翻过来，然后再开始。当我们到达西弗吉尼亚州时，这是旅程的第一个成就：几乎每个人都背下了所有的歌词。
[SINGING] New Kids on the Block had a bunch of hits. Chinese food makes me sick. And I think it's fly when girls stop by for the summer, for the summer.
[演唱] “新街边男孩”有很多热门曲目。中国菜让我恶心。当女孩们在夏天顺道拜访时，我觉得很酷，在这个夏天，在这个夏天。
These are the vessels that God has chosen to come here to help others.
这些就是上帝选择来到这里帮助他人的容器。
[SINGING] I'll take her if I had one wish. But she's been gone since that summer, since that summer.
[演唱] 如果有一个愿望，我会带走她。但她从那个夏天起就离开了，从那个夏天起。
Act Two, Unto the Uttermost Part of the Earth. Everybody stays at an old 4-H camp that had been taken over by the Presbyterian Church of America's national missionary organization, Mission to the World. Kids and adults from all over the country filled the various cabins. Prayers were held in the campfire circle. It was green, shady, spectacularly pretty, with daily sermons from a tattooed ex-Marine everybody called Pastor Kenny.
第二幕，传到地极。大家住在一个旧的4-H营地，这个营地已被美国长老会全国宣教组织“使命世界”接管。来自全国各地的孩子和成年人挤满了各个小屋。在营火圈举行祷告。那里绿树成荫，风景极其优美，每个人都称之为“肯尼牧师”的纹身前海军陆战队员每天都会进行布道。
We've had people come up here for-- this is our sixth summer. And every year, someone comes with the idea that we're going to win West Virginia over to Jesus this week. I'm serious. Now this is true. I'm here to tell you that's not going to happen. It's not going to happen. But if you will open your heart to God this week, God will change your life, and you will never be the same.
我们已经在这儿待了六年了——这是我们第六个夏天。每年都有人带着“我们要在这周赢得西弗吉尼亚州归向耶稣”的想法来到这里。我是认真的，这是真的。我现在要告诉你们，这不会发生。这不会发生。但如果你这周向神敞开心扉，神会改变你的生命，你将永远不再是原来的你。
Right now there's a boom in church projects like this one, that send people on one-to-two-week mission trips. This boom crosses all denominations. There are no great national estimates, but in this one Presbyterian denomination, not the biggest one, the number of short-term missionaries has more than doubled in just three years. Now it's over 5,000 souls. 750 of them came through this West Virginia summer camp this year, and the number's still climbing.
现在，像这样的教会项目正处于繁荣期，它们派遣人们进行为期一到两周的宣教之旅。这种繁荣跨越了所有宗派。虽然没有确切的全国性估计，但仅在这个长老会派别（还不是最大的一个）中，短期宣教士的数量在短短三年内就翻了一番多。现在已经超过了5000人。今年有750人通过这个西弗吉尼亚州的夏令营来到这里，而且人数还在不断增加。
And so, among certain groups of Christian teenagers, going on a mission trip has become a rite of passage. There are upbeat articles and ads in the Christian teen magazines. One of the Chicago girls, Anna, says that of the 11 girls in her class at her old school, a small Christian junior high, all 11 went on mission trips this summer. And when they got to where they were going, they often got a jolt of culture shock. Our group found itself in a small town fixing up a house that had a beautiful sloping yard, apple trees, two porches. Sure, there were trailer homes up the street, but this house was, all and all, not what the kids thought of when they signed up to help the unfortunate. One girl said that she had envisioned something more like Cabrini-Green, the high-rise Chicago public housing project. Kelly, the one whose family has a pool, put it this way.
因此，在某些基督徒青少年群体中，参加宣教之旅已成为一种成年礼。基督教青少年杂志上有欢快的文章和广告。芝加哥女孩之一的安娜说，她以前就读的一所小型基督教初中，班里的11个女孩今年夏天全部参加了宣教之旅。当她们到达目的地时，常常会受到文化冲击。我们的小组发现自己在一个小镇上，正在修缮一栋有着美丽的倾斜院子、苹果树和两个门廊的房子。当然，街上有活动房屋，但这栋房子总的来说并不是孩子们报名帮助不幸者时想到的样子。一个女孩说她预想的情况更像是芝加哥卡布里尼-格林那样的公共住宅高层项目。家里有游泳池的凯莉是这样说的：
I didn't picture-- I mean, this house is a lot bigger than I thought it'd be. I thought it'd be like a rundown little shack. I mean, I didn't picture like, rat clothes, you know?
我没想过——我的意思是，这房子比我想象的大得多。我以为会像个破烂的小棚屋。我的意思是我没想过是那种穷困潦倒的，你知道吗？
Rat clothes, did you say?
你说穷困潦倒？
I don't know. Like, I don't know, like dirt poor. I mean, but it's nice. I mean, it definitely needs some painting work, but you know.
我不知道。就是，我不知道，就像一贫如洗。但它很不错。我是说，它绝对需要粉刷一下，但你知道。
You might think it would be awkward for the recipients of this charity work. If nothing else, to have all the neighbors see a team of out-of-state church kids working on their house. But as it turned out, the neighbors saw the kids and thought that perhaps they were from some kind of work-release boot camp kind of program, like they saw on NBC Dateline, they told us.
你可能认为接受这种慈善工作会很尴尬。至少，让所有的邻居看到一群外州的教会孩子在修他们的房子会很奇怪。但结果证明，邻居们看到这些孩子时，觉得他们可能是某种劳动教养项目的人，就像他们在NBC《Dateline》节目里看到的那样，他们告诉我们。
My dad-- not my family, my husband's family-- all worked in a coal mine.
我父亲——不是我的家人，是我丈夫的家人——都在煤矿工作过。
Pebble Cunningham is 80 years old. She lives in the house that the Chicago group was painting, along with her daughter, who is in her 50s, and her granddaughter, Angie.
佩布尔·坎宁安今年80岁。她和她50多岁的女儿以及孙女安吉住在这栋芝加哥小组正在粉刷的房子里。
I would expect, for somebody like you, whose family's always worked, is it strange to have these people come in and help you out like this?
对于像您这样家里一直都在工作的人来说，有人进来这样帮助你们，会不会觉得奇怪？
It's strange, but it's nice. Because we have no man-power at all. We ain't got no men to help us. This house was going down fast.
奇怪，但很好。因为我们根本没有劳动力。我们没有男人来帮我们。这房子正在迅速倒塌。
But I would think that because you've always been a working family, the notion of having people come in and help out and do charity--
但我以为因为你们一直是一个勤劳的家庭，对于有人进来帮助并进行慈善——
First time. But we loved it. Because we needed it, you know.
第一次。但我们很喜欢。因为我们需要它，你知道。
Now, were you worried, having all these Bible kids come to you, that they'll be trying to preach to you the whole time?
那你们会担心吗？这些圣经孩子来找你们，他们会一直试图向你们传教？
Nah, let 'em talk about it. I [UNINTELLIGIBLE] to look forward to Jesus. [UNINTELLIGIBLE] got to look forward to.
不，让他们说吧。我期待着耶稣。有值得期待的事。
Act Three, Wise as Serpents and Harmless as Doves. Back in Chicago, Dan had said that part of what would bring everybody on the trip closer to God was facing hardship together. And, as if on schedule, the difficulties began our first morning.
第三幕，灵巧像蛇，驯良像鸽子。在芝加哥时，丹曾说，让大家在旅途中更亲近上帝的部分原因是共同面对苦难。正如预料的那样，困难在我们第一天早上就开始了。
Give me yellow hair. No, give me-- give me blue hair.
给我弄个黄头发。不，给我——给我弄个蓝头发。
You've got to give me like-- you've got to give me Scully hair.
你得给我弄个像斯卡莉那样的发型。
The girls sit on the porch of their cabin, bent in concentration with crayons and paper, drawing a get-well card for Dan, with everybody on it. They also gave him Gatorade.
女孩们坐在小屋的门廊上，专注地用蜡笔和纸画一张康复卡给丹，上面画着每个人。她们还给了他佳得乐。
Dan's probably going to have to go to the hospital.
丹可能得去医院了。
Yeah, he's really sick. He's like vomiting, barfing, vomiting, violently.
是的，他病得很厉害。他呕吐、干呕，呕吐得很厉害。
Maybe the Gatorade will just do a--
也许佳得乐会起作用——
Yeah, maybe the Gatorade will work miracles.
是的，也许佳得乐会创造奇迹。
Miracles can happen. That's like in our devotion.
奇迹会发生的。就像我们的灵修课里说的那样。
Dan has some sort of food poisoning. When he goes into the hospital, it sends the four adult leaders on the trip lurching into a dispute over what to do next. And some of Dan's best-laid plans begin to go awry. Take the vacation Bible school. The original plan for the week was that, every morning for a few hours, the kids would split into two different groups. Half would work on painting the Cunninghams' house, half would work on what they call a VBS, which is church-speak for Vacation Bible School, which itself is church-speak for trying to bring the word of God to local kids with games, skits, candy, a brief lesson.
丹患上了某种食物中毒。当他住进医院时，这导致旅途中的四名成年领袖对下一步该怎么做产生了分歧。丹的一些精心策划开始偏离轨道。比如度假圣经学校。本周最初的计划是，每天早上几个小时，孩子们分成两组。一半人在坎宁安家粉刷房子，另一半人进行所谓的“VBS”（度假圣经学校的缩写，在教会语言中指通过游戏、短剧、糖果和简短的课程向当地孩子传播上帝的话语）。
What do we say?
我们怎么说？
We say, we're doing a club. We're a youth group from Chicago.
我们说，我们在办一个俱乐部。我们是来自芝加哥的青年团契。
Anna and Lauren practice what they'll say to round up kids.
安娜和劳伦练习如何召集孩子。
If you have any kids-- should we ask if they have any kids? Or just say, if you have any kids-- if you're interested--
如果你有孩子——我们该问他们是否有孩子吗？还是只说，如果你有任何孩子——如果你感兴趣——
Feel free to have them come.
请随时让他们过来。
But the group got bad advice about where to hold the vacation Bible school. We set up about a 10-minute drive from the Cunningham house in a big, empty public park. And as we went knocking from door to door to advertise the event to kids, it was like a fairy tale, where at each house, the person at the door was slightly more infirm, slightly more elderly, than the person at the house before.
但小组关于在哪里举办度假圣经学校得到了糟糕的建议。我们在距离坎宁安家开车约10分钟路程的一个巨大的空旷公园里设立了场地。当我们挨家挨户敲门宣传这个活动时，就像童话故事一样，每一户人家门口的人都比上一户更虚弱、更年长。
I don't have any children. I don't have any grandchildren here and I don't know anybody that has kids.
我没有孩子。我这里没有孙子孙女，也不认识有孩子的人。
OK. Thank you.
好的。谢谢。
Hi, we were wondering if you had any kids that wanted to come to the backyard Bible club at Worthington Park.
嗨，我们想知道你是否有孩子想参加沃辛顿公园的后院圣经俱乐部。
I don't have any.
我没有。
Do you have any kids? Do you have-- do you have any children?
你有孩子吗？你有——你有任何孩子吗？
And the next day, when we went out to hold the vacation Bible school, with props and costumes and games, with a pre-rehearsed skit and more candy than you might imagine, Karen, Marie, Jessica, Nora, Laura, Kelly, and Arden sat on the edge of an outdoor stage in the park, waiting. Nobody showed up. The closest they came was when a white pickup turned into the parking area.
第二天，当我们带着道具、服装和游戏，准备好短剧和超乎想象的糖果去举办度假圣经学校时，凯伦、玛丽、杰西卡、诺拉、劳拉、凯莉和阿登坐在公园室外舞台的边缘等待。没有人来。最接近的一次是一辆白色皮卡开进了停车场。
Look it! Child! Child?
看！小孩！小孩？
Looks like it could be a family vehicle. [INTERPOSING VOICES]
看起来像是家庭用车。[干扰的声音]
Oh, please!
哦，拜托！
Maybe they have seven kids.
也许他们有七个孩子。
They didn't have seven. Or even one.
他们没有七个。甚至一个都没有。
Oh well.
好吧。
So are we going to come back every day if nobody comes? Is this going to be like three hours of wasted time every day?
所以如果没人来，我们还要每天回来吗？这每天会不会是三个小时的浪费时间？
Two. Two hours.
两个小时。
One of the group leaders, Nora, gathers them around.
小组领袖之一诺拉把大家聚集在一起。
You know, I think that anyone who is led to pray should pray. Chris, can you start us off? And then Laura, can you just finish? Thanks.
你知道，我认为任何有感动祷告的人都应该祷告。克里斯，你能带个头吗？然后劳拉，你能结束吗？谢谢。
They bow their heads. Here's one of the advantages of Christian life over secular life-- that at any moment of trouble, when somebody might get frustrated or mad, or for that matter, at any turning point in the day, when one thing ends and another's about to begin, our group takes a quiet moment and reflects.
他们低下头。这是基督徒生活优于世俗生活的一个优势——在任何麻烦时刻，当有人可能感到沮丧或愤怒时，或者在那一天的任何转折点，当一件事结束、另一件事即将开始时，我们的小组会进行片刻安静的反思。
Dear Lord, we came here today, and we were really hoping that we'd be able to teach some kids about God, but it didn't work out that way. And maybe you're just showing us that it's better to go back to the house and work with the family there. But please show us some more signs.
亲爱的主，我们今天来到这里，真的很希望能教一些孩子认识你，但事情并没有如愿。也许你只是在向我们展示，回到房子里和那里的家人一起工作会更好。但请给我们展示更多的迹象。
Dear Lord, I want to thank you so much for this day, and that it was nice. And I just pray that we won't be discouraged that no kids will come. And that maybe-- well, you said that everything is worked for the good. And maybe we needed more time on the house, Lord. And I just pray that whatever happens, that good things will come out of this and we'll all do it for your glory.
亲爱的主，我非常感谢你赐予这一天，它很美好。我祈祷我们不会因为没人来而灰心。也许——嗯，你说过万事互相效力。也许我们在房子上需要更多的时间，主啊。我祈祷无论发生什么，好的结果都会从中产生，我们都会为了你的荣耀而做。
Talking with the kids afterwards, I found that the lesson that they took from this experience was not that they could have chosen a better location or done a better job finding kids. It was not that they could have tried harder. What they all told me simply was, was that this was God's will.
事后与孩子们交谈，我发现他们从这次经历中吸取的教训并不是他们本可以选择更好的地点或更努力地寻找孩子。也不是他们本可以更努力。他们简单地告诉我的，是这就是上帝的旨意。
It's a lesson that seems, to a secular person, strangely at odds with the job of raising children. It seems, in fact, to be exactly the opposite of what you would want to teach a child. Raising kids is, after all, a process of convincing them that they have to be responsible. That if something goes wrong, they have to figure out if there was anything they could have done to prevent it. I talked to Dan about this. I talked to the other adult leaders about it. And finally, the only person on the trip who says anything convincing about why this notion of God's will might be a good thing to teach teenagers is Ruth, the oldest girl in the youth group.
对于一个世俗的人来说，这个教训似乎与抚养孩子的工作奇怪地不一致。事实上，这似乎恰恰与你想教给孩子的东西相反。毕竟，抚养孩子是一个让他们相信自己必须负责的过程。如果事情出了差错，他们必须找出是否有任何预防措施可以采取。我和丹谈过这个，和其他成年领袖也谈过。最后，这次旅行中唯一一个对为什么要教青少年上帝旨意这个概念给出令人信服解释的人，是青年团契中年龄最大的女孩露丝。
That helps me through the day. Because you see kids who don't care at all, you know, about Jesus and all of that, and they seem to be doing just fine. They seem to be doing a lot better. Because I'm in this really competitive program. And a lot of the kids are not Christians. And a lot of kids do really well. One of my classmates, I think, scored a perfect on the ACT. And I didn't. I mean, I wasn't very close. And I may take it over, I may not. The point is that, I don't know, they seem to be doing better. And sometimes I think, boy, I wish that I could do that well. And I guess it wasn't God's plan for me to do that well. It just seems like just knowing that, it's not all under our control, and that maybe that God does have a plan, so whatever He chooses-- though I may not like it, and I certainly don't like not coming out on top or not being the best.
这能帮我度过每一天。因为你会看到那些根本不在乎耶稣和这一切的孩子，他们似乎过得很好。他们似乎做得更好。因为我参加的是一个竞争非常激烈的项目。很多孩子不是基督徒。而且很多孩子表现得非常好。我认为我的一位同学ACT得了满分。但我没有。我的意思是我差得远。我可能会重考，也可能不会。重点是，我不知道，他们似乎做得更好。有时我想，天哪，我希望我也能做得那么好。我想上帝对我做得那么好并不是他的计划。我猜，知道这并不是一切都在我们的控制之中，而且也许上帝确实有一个计划，无论他选择什么——尽管我可能不喜欢它，而且我当然不喜欢没能名列前茅或不是最棒的。
Act Four, Your Name Is Ointment Poured Forth. One great thing about staying in a camp with 130 other Christians, if you're a young Christian girl who has never had a boyfriend, is the much-better-than-in-school chance of meeting a nice, cute, Christian boy. Though, of course, camp rules prohibit anything more than having a crush from afar. This turns out not to cramp the style of the Chicago girls, however. A crush from afar is exactly as far as they could handle.
第四幕，你的膏油芬芳。如果你是一个从未交过男朋友的年轻基督徒女孩，住在有130名其他基督徒的营地里，有一个远比在学校里见到可爱、帅气的基督徒男孩的机会，这是一件伟大的事情。当然，营地规则禁止除了远距离倾慕以外的任何行为。然而，事实证明这并没有限制住芝加哥女孩们的风格。远距离倾慕正是她们所能处理的极限。
Monday night, after services and after devotions, everybody is milling around the volleyball court in the center of camp. There are boys and girls there. And one of the adult leaders, Nora, comes down carrying a word game for everybody to play. A word game. What could be more embarrassing?
周一晚上，在礼拜和灵修之后，每个人都在营地中心的排球场附近徘徊。那里有男孩也有女孩。其中一位成年领袖诺拉拿来了一个供大家玩的文字游戏。一个文字游戏。还有比这更尴尬的吗？
First, Nora comes out. She's like, anyone up for a game of Boggle? She comes marching down. These kids start staring at her. And now everyone in our [? deal ?] just starts laughing.
首先，诺拉出来了。她说，有谁想玩Boggle游戏吗？她走过来。这些孩子开始盯着她看。现在我们这边所有人都开始笑了。
Kelly, who cheerfully describes herself as the most boy crazy of the group, explains that it was Anna, who just didn't care what anyone thought, who spoke up to say that she liked Boggle. Which turned out to be a master stroke.
凯莉愉快地形容自己是小组里最疯狂追求男孩的一个，她解释说，是安娜，那个根本不在乎别人怎么想的人，主动说她喜欢Boggle。这结果证明是一个绝妙的一招。
--Boggle. And so then we end up starting to play this Boggle game and other people come by. Like--
——Boggle。所以我们最终开始玩这个Boggle游戏，其他人也过来了。比如——
These two guys from Virginia.
这两个来自弗吉尼亚的家伙。
Ran.
Ran。
I found barn.
我找到了barn。
Sun.
Sun。
Nor.
Nor。
Shay. Band.
Shay。Band。
First it started with Lauren and Ruthie. They like Jimbo. I mean, he's too old, but he's really cute. Then there is Andy, who Jessica and Anna think is cute. And then there's Ben who's really-- everyone thinks he's cute. But not-- but they all have their first choice. But he looks like-- Jessica thinks he looks like an Abercrombie model. He does.
起初是劳伦和露丝。她们喜欢吉姆博。我的意思是，他太大了，但他真的很可爱。然后是安迪，杰西卡和安娜觉得他很可爱。还有本，真的——每个人都觉得他很可爱。但不是——他们都有自己的首选。但他看起来像——杰西卡认为他看起来像个Abercrombie模特。他确实像。
All right, yes. I am extremely ticklish. Thank you for reminding me.
好的，是的。我非常怕痒。谢谢你提醒我。
During the game, a girl came over and started rubbing Ben's shoulders.
在游戏过程中，一个女孩走过来开始按摩本的肩膀。
His little massage girlfriend came over and was massaging him, and he was like, you know what? Stop. Didn't he get a little aggravated? Well, he did get a little aggravated.
他的那个小按摩“女朋友”走过来按摩他，他当时说，你知道吗？停下。他难道没有觉得有点恼火吗？嗯，他确实觉得有点恼火。
Did you guys make eye contact or talk?
你们有过眼神交流或交谈吗？
Yes, we did! He first-- it was eye contact. [INAUDIBLE] Hey, she asked me! And so first, we were like, we were playing Boggle. You know how to play. You find the words. And I was like, oh, I found a word. And he's like, I already found that word. I was like, oh, I'm sorry. And so then, at the end of the game, he was telling me how he really stunk at the game. And that was basically it.
是的，有过！他首先——那是眼神交流。[无法听清] 嘿，是她问我的！所以首先，我们就像，我们在玩Boggle。你知道怎么玩。你找单词。我就说，哦，我找到了一个单词。他说，我已经找到那个单词了。我说，哦，对不起。所以后来，在游戏结束时，他告诉我他在这游戏上真的很烂。基本就是这样。
Not very romantic, Kelly admits. But after that, every night after their missionary work, the Chicago girls shower, apply lip gloss, and blow dry their hair straight, so they're ready for the volleyball court after devotions.
凯莉承认，这不是很浪漫。但从那以后，每天宣教工作结束后，芝加哥女孩们都会洗澡、涂唇彩，把头发吹直，以便灵修结束后在排球场做好准备。
Joel, who has the most protective parents of anybody in the group, is not indulging any crushy feelings very far on this trip.
乔尔，他在小组里有最保护他的父母，这次旅行中没有太沉迷于倾慕的感觉。
This plan I'm kind of laying off, because my parents-- they're kind of strict on this issue. So like you're not allowed to date until we're dead. Seriously, I'm not allowed to date anybody until they're dead.
这个计划我正在搁置，因为我父母——他们在这个问题上有点严格。所以就像在你死之前你是不准约会的。真的，在我死之前我不准和任何人约会。
Until they're dead?
直到他们死了？
Until they're dead.
直到他们死了。
That is not the rule.
那不是规则。
That is too. I'm not allowed to date. They're into this new-- this courtship idea where the families, both the families get together, and then the two people get to know each other in the family setting. But you know, not going out by ourselves where our parents can't keep track of us. I mean we can sit and talk, you know, with our parents across the room or whatever. And it starts getting farther and farther away until-- as we get older and more responsible and more mature, then it starts getting a little more one on one. As we get more responsible then it's going out to dinner and stuff.
那确实是。我不准约会。他们沉迷于这种新的——这种求爱想法，就是两家人聚在一起，然后两个人能在家庭环境中了解彼此。但你知道，不能在父母看不见我们的情况下自己出去。我的意思是我们可以坐着聊天，父母坐在房间对面什么的。然后距离越来越远，直到——随着我们长大，变得更负责任、更成熟，然后就开始变得更一对一了。随着我们变得更负责任，就可以出去吃晚饭之类的。
Joel says that he's going through a period of questioning his faith right now. And the most emotionally charged questions that he's asking have to do with sex, the outright ban on premarital sex. What is a 13-year-old boy supposed to think? Joel says that he's planning on reading all the Biblical references on it so he can understand the reasoning and so he can see for himself if there's any wiggle room in the whole thing. He borrows his mom's theological books on hard subjects like this. When producer Susan Burton asks him if he has a Bible verse that's a particular favorite, he pulls a scrap of paper from his wallet.
乔尔说他现在正处于怀疑信仰的时期。他提出的最情绪化的问题与性有关，即完全禁止婚前性行为。一个13岁的男孩该怎么想？乔尔说他打算读所有关于此的圣经参考资料，这样他就能理解推理过程，并亲自看看这整件事是否有回旋余地。他借了母亲关于这些棘手话题的神学书籍。当制片人苏珊·伯顿问他是否有特别喜欢的圣经经文时，他从钱包里掏出一张纸条。
I have it written down. I always keep it with me. My mom gave it to me, actually.
我把它写下来了。我一直随身带着。其实是我妈妈给我的。
So this is a-- it's a little piece of paper cut out in a circle. Is that your writing?
所以这是一张——这是一小块剪成圆形的纸。这是你的字迹吗？
No, this is my mom's writing. She wrote it down for me. 2 Timothy 2:22. "Flee also youthful lusts. But pursue righteousness, faith, love, peace with those who call on the Lord out of a pure heart." Which basically means, for me, stay away from what I want to do at this time.
不，这是我妈妈的笔迹。她为我写下来的。《提摩太后书》2:22。“你要逃避少年的私欲，同那清心祷告主的人追求公义、信德、仁爱、和平。”这对我来说基本意味着，远离我这个年纪想做的事情。
It was sometime early in the week that Susan and I met Matt [? Gerkin ?] and Eric [? Highland. ?] They saw us standing with our Chicago interviewees, holding our tape recorders and boom mics, and strolled right up.
大概是在周初，苏珊和我遇到了马特·格金和埃里克·海兰。他们看到我们和芝加哥的受访者站在一起，手里拿着录音机和吊杆麦克风，便径直走了过来。
We were thinking we heard something in the woods here last night. We're investigating it.
我们认为昨晚在树林里听到了一些声音。我们正在调查。
This is just weeks after the movie Blair Witch Project hit theaters. Matt is 18, Eric's 23, and it becomes clear after some questioning that, in fact, they have no intention of going into the woods. They just said that, trying to get on the radio.
这距离电影《布莱尔女巫》上映仅仅过了几周。马特18岁，埃里克23岁，经过询问后显而易见，事实上他们根本没打算去树林。他们只是想上电台才那么说的。
So what really gets on the radio? Do you have to do something dramatic to get on the radio? Or you want real life?
那么什么才能真正上电台呢？你必须做些戏剧性的事情才能上电台吗？还是你想要真实生活？
We explain that we're doing a documentary story, which means we tell him that he'd have a better chance of getting on the air if he goes through some sort of change over the course of his week of missionary work.
我们解释说我们在做一个纪录片故事，这意味着我们告诉他，如果他在这一周的宣教工作中经历了一些改变，上电台的机会会更大。
So if we can find something that would really change our lives, and we wanted it documented and broadcasted across the nation, we'd call you guys, and we'd like--
所以如果我们能找到真正改变我们生活的事情，并且我们希望它被记录并向全国广播，我们会给你们打电话，我们就像——
If something happens to you this week that changed your life, you find me, and you'll be on the radio.
如果这周发生了什么改变你生活的事情，你来找我，你就能上电台。
Really? Wow. So you know what we need to do, is just check in with you every half hour and let you know how we're progressing and how things are happening with us. Change is bad. What's the name of this show? Change? What's with this change talk? If we want to change--!
真的吗？哇。所以你知道我们需要做什么，就是每半小时和你核对一下，让你知道我们的进展以及我们身上发生了什么。改变是坏的。这个节目叫什么名字？改变？这些改变的谈话是怎么回事？如果我们想改变——！
After that, as you'd expect, we ran into them every single day. And every single day, they had so much to say to us about all the changes they were going through.
从那以后，正如你所预料的那样，我们每天都会遇到他们。而且每一天，他们都有那么多关于他们正在经历的所有改变的话题要告诉我们。
Coming up, how even M&Ms and Starburst can serve the Lord. In a minute, on Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，M&Ms和Starburst糖果如何侍奉主。一分钟后，国际公共广播电台节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Most weeks on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today we are devoting our entire show to just one story about a group of suburban Chicago teenagers on their first church mission trip to West Virginia to fix up the house of a family who needs some help, and to witness for God. We've arrived at Act Five of our show. Act Five, The Substance of Things Hoped For.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，我们节目的大多数周都会选择一个主题，带给您关于该主题的各种不同故事。今天我们将整场节目献给一个关于一群芝加哥郊区青少年第一次去西弗吉尼亚州教会宣教之旅的故事，他们去修缮一个需要帮助的家庭的房子，并为上帝做见证。我们已经到了节目的第五幕。第五幕，所望之事的实质。
By Tuesday, Dan's feeling better, and one of the first things he does at the work site is drop in on the neighbors.
到了周二，丹感觉好多了，他在工作现场做的第一件事就是顺便去看看邻居。
I'm Dan. What was your name again?
我是丹。你叫什么名字来着？
Crystal and Paula.
克里斯托和宝拉。
And this is Marisa.
这是玛丽莎。
Hi.
嗨。
When Dan came out during the winter to see the house that they would be fixing up, he met these teenage girls. Back then, one of them, Crystal, said the month that Dan was bringing the group out was going to be the same month as her birthday, and Dan came back prepared.
当丹冬天来考察他们将要修缮的房子时，他见到了这些少女。那时，其中一个女孩克里斯托说，丹带团来那个月刚好是她生日，丹回来时做好了准备。
Well, are we going to celebrate the birthday? You said we were going to celebrate when we came here.
我们要庆祝生日吗？你说我们来这里的时候要庆祝。
His accent migrates below the Mason-Dixon as he explains.
他的口音在解释时流露出梅森-迪克森线以下的味道。
We actually have a little present for you. Because we knew it was going to be your birthday, so one of the girls went out and got a little present for you. So. Well, if you guys ever get bored and want to come over there, there's a bunch of people. We're going to be here all week. We'd love to talk to you. We got some candy and stuff. Introduce yourself to them. And if you want to come by, we're going to be eating lunch. What time do we eat lunch?
我们其实给你准备了一个小礼物。因为我们知道那是你的生日，所以其中一个女孩出去给你买了个小礼物。所以。好吧，如果你们感到无聊想过来看看，那里有一群人。我们要在这里待一整周。我们很乐意和你们交谈。我们有一些糖果之类的。向他们介绍一下自己。如果你们想过来，我们午饭时间要在那儿吃。我们什么时候吃午饭？
Like 12:00.
大概12点吧。
12:00. We got some-- you can eat with us. We've got some candy and food and drinks.
12点。我们有——你们可以和我们一起吃。我们有一些糖果、食物和饮料。
Back next door, everybody works on the Cunninghams' house. Scraping off the old paint, rolling on the new, trimming back bushes, climbing up ladders. Everybody dressed in surgical scrubs, those blue-green cotton pajamas that you see the doctors wear on ER. That is, if your faith allows you to watch ER. They're light, they're disposable, and they let you call each other doctor all day long.
在隔壁，大家都在坎宁安家工作。刮掉旧油漆，刷上新的，修剪灌木，爬上梯子。每个人都穿着手术洗手服，就是你在《急诊室的故事》里看到医生穿的那种蓝绿色棉质睡衣。前提是你的信仰允许你看《急诊室的故事》。它们很轻、是一次性的，还能让你整天互相称呼“医生”。
The work goes quickly. At some point, to dislodge some ancient paint off aluminum siding, the adults drag in an industrial power washer that they warn the kids about so frighteningly, some get sort of spooked.
工作进行得很快。在某个时候，为了从铝壁板上清除古老的油漆，大人们搬来了一个工业动力清洗机，他们警告孩子们要小心，甚至吓到了某些人。
I don't know. I'm afraid to use the power hose thing. Because I feel like I'm going to kill somebody. And I mean seriously kill somebody.
我不知道。我害怕使用那个高压软管的东西。因为我觉得我会杀了某人。我是说真的杀了某人。
Lindsay stands in line, deciding if she'll take a turn.
琳赛排着队，决定是否要轮到她。
I don't want to see it.
我不想看。
Once the power washer gets going, Ruth is the first one to use it to actually remove paint.
一旦动力清洗机开始工作，露丝是第一个真正用它清除油漆的人。
It's fun, yeah. I'm the oldest, so I like the power.
这很有趣，是的。我是最大的，所以我喜欢这种力量。
Among an earlier generation of Christian women, or among more fundamentalist Christian women, there might be some question about whether it is a woman's place to run the power tools in the family. This question is so irrelevant to these Presbyterian teenagers that when I bring it up they literally do not know what I'm talking about.
在老一代基督徒女性中，或者在更原教旨主义的基督徒女性中，对于女性在家庭中操作电动工具是否合宜可能存在疑问。这些长老会的青少年对这个问题完全不了解，当我提起时，她们简直不知道我在说什么。
While they all work on the house, every now and then somebody from the Cunningham family is spotted. And every single time, it is like the experience that you have when you spot a minor celebrity. Your heart leaps. It's all you can think about. And then, if you're brave enough to stroll over and chat, you try to play it casual. Like, oh, we're just talking here. I'm relaxed. It's just like talking to anybody. After all, they are here to minister to this family.
当她们都在房子上工作时，偶尔会看到坎宁安家的人。每次看到时，那种感觉就像你偶然发现一个小名人一样。你的心跳加速。你满脑子想的都是这个。然后，如果你勇敢地走过去闲聊，你会尽量表现得随和。就像，哦，我们只是在这聊天。我很放松。这就像和任何人交谈一样。毕竟，她们是来服务这个家庭的。
When the Cunninghams' daughter, Angie, comes out on the porch one afternoon, Kelly and Jessica do their best to be friendly. And for once, Kelly's mother might feel like she did the right thing buying her daughter all those Backstreet Boy CDs. Because now they get the chance to talk Backstreet Boys on the Lord's behalf. Paula and Crystal, the girls from next door, bring over a Backstreet Boys poster. Angie owns a t-shirt from the '98 tour.
一天下午，当坎宁安家的女儿安吉走上门廊时，凯莉和杰西卡尽力表现得友好。而这一次，凯莉的母亲可能会觉得给女儿买那些后街男孩的CD是正确的做法。因为现在她们有机会代表主来谈论后街男孩。邻居家的女孩宝拉和克里斯托拿来了一张后街男孩的海报。安吉拥有一件98年巡演的T恤。
Angie is actually in her late 20s. She has a small disability in one of her arms. It's shorter than the other and her hand on that arm isn't fully functional. Most days she stays at home, watching TV. It is inherently difficult for the Chicago teenagers to figure out how to interact with, even how to react to, somebody from such a different background. And there's a certain amount of raw confusion as they feel their way forward. Every night back at camp, after prayers and devotionals, they all debrief about the day.
安吉其实已经快30岁了。她的一只手臂有轻微的残疾。它比另一只短，而且那只手的功能也不完全。大部分时间她都待在家里看电视。对于芝加哥青少年来说，弄清楚如何与背景如此不同的人互动，甚至如何反应，是极其困难的。在她们摸索前进时，有一定程度的原始困惑。每晚回到营地，在祷告和灵修之后，她们都会汇报当天的进展。
So anyone have any thoughts about today? Positive, negative feedback? Anything?
那么有人对今天有什么想法吗？正面、负面的反馈？有什么吗？
Kelly uses the chance to speak up.
凯莉趁机发言。
I thought, at first, it was kind of hard to talk to Angie, just because, I mean, I didn't like staring. I mean, I didn't want to. And it's not just because of her arm. It's because it is hard to understand her, and she didn't really get what you said sometimes. But at first I was kind of doing it out of pity for her, and then that didn't feel right, you know? I didn't want to do it out of pity for her. And I don't know if it's wrong or right to do it out of pity for her. But that's how I'm doing it. And I don't know if that's right. I just-- and it makes me so happy when I see her smile. And it's just-- I guess I don't know if it's right or wrong to do it out of pity. I know I keep asking that. So someone answer.
起初，我觉得和安吉说话有点困难，因为——我的意思是，我不想盯着看。我的意思是不只是因为她的手臂。是因为很难理解她，有时她没听懂你在说什么。但起初我有点出于同情她才那么做，然后这感觉不太对，你知道吗？我不想出于同情才做。我不知道出于同情这么做是错还是对。但我就是这么做的。而且我不知道这是否正确。我只是——看到她微笑时我感到很高兴。而且这只是——我猜我不知道出于同情做这件事是对还是错。我知道我一直在问这个问题。所以有人回答一下。
Nobody does for a while, until later, when Dan says the perfect thing, that when Jesus walked the earth, he didn't feel pity for the sick and handicapped. He felt compassion, empathy. Lauren offers this optimistic thought.
没人回答，直到后来，丹说出了那句完美的话：当耶稣走在地上时，他并没有对病残者感到“同情”（怜悯），而是感到了同情（共情）。劳伦提出了这个乐观的想法。
She obviously has a lot of problems with her deformity and whatever. And I was just thinking, in heaven, she's not going to have any deformity. And if we can reach her that way--
她显然因为残疾或其他原因有很多问题。我刚才在想，在天堂里，她不会有任何残疾。如果我们能以那种方式接触到她——
Over and over, Dan tells the group that their main purpose in coming to West Virginia is to minister to the family whose house they're working on. Getting to know Angie is important, he says.
丹反复告诉小组成员，他们来西弗吉尼亚州的主要目的是服务他们正在修缮房子的那个家庭。他说，了解安吉很重要。
Remember the names. I know I need it. I kept telling Carol, Carol, what were their names again? Really, they love that they're going to know their names. I thought it was great you guys were showing your boy bands. I thought that was great. I thought that was great. And they say they go to that church. I asked them if they have youth group events and they said they've done a couple youth group events. So I think, you know, if the timing is right, I think you have a good opportunity to just ask them, well, what do you think about God? I mean, I don't think it would be awkward at all. I just think I would encourage you, and be praying about it, that if you feel like the motivation is there, man, just plant a seed. Just see what happens, and maybe you're going to go with it.
记住名字。我知道我需要。我一直告诉卡罗尔，卡罗尔，她们的名字叫什么来着？真的，她们喜欢别人知道她们的名字。我觉得你们展示男孩乐队很棒。我觉得这很好。我觉得这很好。她们说她们去那个教堂。我问她们是否参加过青年团契活动，她们说参加过几个。所以我认为，你知道，如果时机成熟，我认为你们有很好的机会问她们，嗯，你们怎么看上帝？我的意思是，我觉得这根本不尴尬。我只是想鼓励你们，并为此祷告，如果你们觉得动机存在，伙计，种下一颗种子。看看会发生什么，也许你会顺其自然。
Listening to all this, I imagine how disturbed Angie and Crystal and Paula might be if they overheard all the scheming of how they'll be befriended. From their point of view, after all, their interaction with the Chicago girls is as simple as, they seem sort of cool. They like them. But missionary work is, at some level, like any sales work. There's no way to do it without discussing some sort of sales strategy. All of these evening sessions end with prayer, in which anybody who wants to say something simply speaks up. And a lot of the prayers are about Angie, and the two neighbors, Crystal and Paula. Kelly was among those offering a prayer.
听着这一切，我想象着如果安吉、克里斯托和宝拉听到所有关于如何与她们建立友谊的密谋，会感到多么不安。毕竟在她们看来，她们与芝加哥女孩们的互动很简单：她们看起来挺酷的。她们喜欢她们。但宣教工作在某种程度上像任何销售工作。不讨论某种销售策略是不可能的。所有这些晚间会议都以祷告结束，任何想说点什么的人都会发言。很多祷告都是关于安吉以及那两个邻居克里斯托和宝拉的。凯莉也在祈祷者之中。
I just pray that tomorrow we'd really get to talk to Mrs. Cunningham and Angela and just really be a witness for you, Lord.
我祈祷明天我们真的能和坎宁安夫人和安吉谈谈，真正为主做一个见证，主啊。
I especially pray for Angela, and just help us to ask the right questions, and to think of things to say and talk about with her. And to find out exactly what makes her tick inside and what makes her special.
我特别为安吉祈祷，帮助我们问出正确的问题，想到可以说和谈论的事情。找出她内心深处到底是什么让她动心，什么让她变得特别。
Pray for Angela, that she'll just really get to know us. That we won't be like every other group and that we'll just really, really get to know her as a really good friend.
为安吉祈祷，她真的能了解我们。我们不会像其他小组一样，我们真的，真的能和她成为很好的朋友。
And from there, everybody headed to the volleyball court, where-- I am sorry to report-- the Chicagoans lost. Lauren's second serve went straight to the guy she sort of had a crush on, and he spiked it like he didn't even know she existed.
从那里，每个人都前往排球场，在那里——我遗憾地报告——芝加哥队输了。劳伦的第二个发球直奔她暗恋的那个男孩，他像根本不知道她存在一样扣杀了它。
Come on, Lindsay!
得了吧，琳赛！
Susan, meanwhile, is watching the volleyball game from the sidelines when those two guys, Matt and Eric, who want to be on the radio, show right up.
与此同时，苏珊在场边观看排球比赛，那两个想上电台的家伙，马特和埃里克出现了。
All right, the game is getting very exciting at this point.
好吧，比赛现在变得非常激动人心。
Yeah, why don't you guys narrate the rest of the game for me, OK?
是的，你们为什么不帮我解说剩下的比赛呢，好吗？
All right. It has been-- [INTERPOSING VOICES]. Ball returned to the Chicago team and Chicago returns with a bunt over the net! It is returned! And it is on! Chicago has done it! Oh! [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
好的。这已经——[干扰的声音]。球传回给芝加哥队，芝加哥队以一个过网的轻吊回击！球被接回了！比赛继续！芝加哥队做到了！哦！[无法听清]
Afterwards, naturally, they insist that-- guess what?-- this has changed them.
事后，自然地，他们坚持认为——猜猜怎么着？——这改变了他们。
This game just now has made us appreciate volleyball even less than we ever did before.
刚才这场比赛让我们对排球的欣赏比以往任何时候都少。
--on the American volleyball team. I'm going to be the official spiker.
——在美式排球队。我要成为官方扣球手。
The evening ended the way every other evening did on the trip. In the cabin, the Chicago crew sang a doxology and then one other song.
夜晚像旅途中的每一个夜晚一样结束。在小屋里，芝加哥队唱了一首荣耀颂，然后唱了另一首歌。
[SINGING] When I say that I want it that way.
[演唱] 当我说我想要那样时。
The Backstreet Boys, "Tell Me Why."
后街男孩的《Tell Me Why》。
[SINGING] Tell me why, ain't nothin' but a heartache. Tell me why. Ain't nothin' but a mistake--
[演唱] 告诉我为什么，这只是心痛。告诉我为什么。这只是个错误——
Act Six, The Evidence of Things Not Seen.
第六幕，所不见之事的证据。
Well, if any of your buddies live around here that didn't get candy, you let us know and we'll get them some.
好吧，如果你们住在这里的朋友没拿到糖果，让我们知道，我们会给他们一些。
This is Dan, trying to attract kids to vacation Bible school, literally by walking down the street and passing out handfuls of candy.
这是丹，试图通过走在大街上分发糖果来吸引孩子们参加度假圣经学校。
You guys just been hanging out?
你们刚才一直在闲逛？
Which turns out to be surprisingly effective.
这结果证明出人意料地有效。
Is this your brother? You got some candy, too, Christopher? Excellent.
这是你弟弟吗？你也拿了一些糖果吗，克里斯托弗？太棒了。
The idea is give up on their first location where nobody showed up for Bible school. Just do it around the corner from the house they're painting. And what clinched the whole deal, the two teenage girls from next door, Crystal and Paula, took Dan and the Chicago kids from door to door, rounding up prospects. In all, about a dozen kids showed up Thursday morning for games, t-shirt painting, and a lesson from the Bible presented in the form of a skit.
主意是放弃第一个没人参加圣经学校的地点。就在我们要粉刷的房子的拐角处进行。最终促成这一切的是隔壁的两个少女，克里斯托和宝拉，她们带着丹和芝加哥的孩子们挨家挨户敲门，寻找潜在参与者。总共大约有十几名孩子周四早上来参加游戏、T恤绘画，并听了一个以短剧形式呈现的圣经课。
So let's everyone close their eyes and we're going to pray. God, we thank you for this day. We thank you for everyone that made it here today. And I pray that we can have a fun time now, we can learn through your skit, and then we could also enjoy doing our craft and playing some more games, and having a snack. In your precious name, amen. Now, with no further ado--
那么让我们每个人闭上眼睛开始祷告。神啊，我们感谢你这一天。我们感谢今天所有来到这里的人。我祈祷我们现在能玩得开心，我们可以通过短剧学习，然后我们也可以享受做手工、多做游戏和吃零食的快乐。奉你宝贵的名，阿们。现在，不用多说——
The whole Bible school turns out to be really fun, for the West Virginia kids and the Chicago ones, too. The games go over great. The crafts absorb everybody. Some of the kids clearly have hard lives and are excited at all the attention they're getting. The only thing lacking is nonbelievers. All the kids say they go to church. When it comes time to make beaded faith bracelets, they already know what all the beads stand for. During Dan's homily, most of the kids know the Bible stories he tells.
整个圣经学校证明真的很有趣，对于西弗吉尼亚州的孩子和芝加哥的孩子来说都是如此。游戏效果很好。手工吸引了每个人。有些孩子显然生活艰辛，对他们得到的关注感到兴奋。唯一缺少的是非信徒。所有的孩子都说他们去教堂。当制作珠子信仰手链时，他们已经知道所有珠子代表什么。在丹的布道期间，大多数孩子都知道他讲的圣经故事。
You guys know the story about the Red Sea, though, right? Well, here's a good story about the Red Sea.
不过你们都知道关于红海的故事，对吧？好吧，这是一个关于红海的好故事。
He just tapped the water and--
他只是拍了拍水，然后——
Right, tapped the water and what happened?
对了，拍了拍水，发生了什么？
It split.
它分开了。
Later, Carol and Marisa are kneeling in the grass doing Bible study when Angie and Crystal just walk right up to them. This is pretty much a situation that any missionary would regard as ideal. And, having no choice, as if a greater plan is, in fact, at work, the Chicagoans get down to the hardcore work of talking about religion. Crystal goes home to get her Bible. One of the adult leaders, Carol, does most of the talking, with Jessica and Kelly and Marisa piping in from time to time.
后来，卡罗尔和玛丽莎跪在草地上查经时，安吉和克里斯托径直走了过来。这几乎是任何宣教士都会认为理想的情况。于是，别无选择，就好像有一个更大的计划在运作，芝加哥人开始进行谈论宗教的艰苦工作。克里斯托回家拿她的圣经。成年领袖之一卡罗尔说得最多，杰西卡、凯莉和玛丽莎不时插嘴。
Does Paula have a Bible, too, that she reads? Yeah? So that's interesting that your school gave you a Bible. Is it like-- [INTERPOSING VOICES] a religious school? Your school did it, too. Is it a religious school? Do they talk about God at school?
宝拉也有她读的圣经吗？是吗？所以很有趣，你们学校给了你一本圣经。是——[干扰的声音]一所宗教学校吗？你们学校也做了。是一所宗教学校吗？他们在学校谈论上帝吗？
No.
没有。
No? They just gave you a Bible? That's kind of cool.
没有？他们只是给了你一本圣经？那挺酷的。
Yeah, if any of the public schools gave us a Bible in Chicago, they'd be in trouble. They're not allowed to do that.
是的，如果芝加哥的公立学校给我们圣经，他们会有麻烦的。他们不允许那样做。
During breaks, all the girls chat happily with the neighborhood kids. And later, back at camp, Dan congratulated them all.
休息期间，女孩们和社区的孩子们聊得很开心。后来，回到营地，丹祝贺了她们所有人。
You guys did so well today. I'm so proud of you, of how you guys were. All of you just seemed to-- really, when you saw them, you were very friendly. With Paula, Crystal, and with Angie. Thank you so much. And let's keep that up tomorrow. This is a great-- I mean, I would say that, of all the people, including all the VBS kids that we've had, the most seeds that we've been planting have been with those three girls.
你们今天做得太好了。我为你们感到骄傲，关于你们的表现。你们所有人都似乎——真的，当你看到她们时，你们非常友好。对待宝拉、克里斯托和安吉。非常感谢。明天让我们继续保持。这是一个伟大的——我的意思是，我会说，在所有人中，包括我们所有的VBS孩子，我们一直在播下的种子最多的是那三个女孩。
It had been Dan's hope that on this trip, the group's faith would deepen. That they would make a step toward having a faith that was independent of what their parents taught them. This would partly happen through service, by helping others, and partly by being forced to articulate their faith to others. And it would happen by facing hardship on the trip and turning to God to help with the difficulties. But the fact is the hardships on the trip turned out to be not very hard at all, and most of them only had to articulate their faith to six-year-olds, who had mostly already accepted Jesus into their hearts. This was not enough to launch a round of soul searching and prayer.
丹曾希望这次旅行能深化小组的信仰。他们能迈出走向拥有独立于父母所教导的信仰的一步。这部分通过服务、通过帮助他人，部分通过被迫向他人表达信仰来实现。而且这将通过在旅途中面对苦难并转向神寻求帮助来完成。但事实是，旅途中的艰辛并没有那么困难，她们中的大多数人只需要向六岁的孩子表达信仰，而这些孩子大多已经接受耶稣进入了他们的心里。这不足以引发一轮自我审视和祷告。
Instead, what happened was that the kids who didn't doubt their faith at home didn't doubt it here either. And the kids who had all sorts of questions at home continued to gnaw at those questions on the mission trip. The teenager with the most doubts was Arden, who mostly kept her doubts to herself.
相反，发生的事情是，那些在家不怀疑自己信仰的孩子在这里也没有怀疑。而那些在家有各种问题的孩子在宣教之旅中继续咀嚼这些问题。怀疑最多的是阿登，她大多把疑虑藏在心里。
Which is really, it's frustrating. It makes it hard. To be-- wanting to be part of the group, and being part of the group, and yet knowing that in some way you're not part of the group because you question what the group is about.
这真的很令人沮丧。这让一切变得艰难。想要成为小组的一员，并且身在其中，但又知道自己在某种程度上不是小组的一员，因为你质疑这个小组的意义。
Arden holds a special symbolic place in her church. She was the first baby born to the young congregation, 15 years ago. Whenever the kids in church formed their own ad hoc church youth groups, Arden was always president. But about a year ago, even this carefully raised girl started to grapple with doubt. And her doubt began, not because of something she saw on television, not because of peer pressure from attractive, cigarette-smoking, alcohol-drinking, pornographic-website-using fans of the South Park movie. No. Her doubts began at church camp. She was there for six weeks, at a program called Discipleship Training, which sent her and five girls that she'd never met before into the woods for two weeks of camping and hiking and canoeing together.
阿登在她的教会中拥有一个特殊的象征性地位。她是15年前这个年轻会众出生的第一个婴儿。每当教会里的孩子组成自己的临时教会青年团契时，阿登总是主席。但大约一年前，即使是这个被精心抚养的女孩也开始挣扎于怀疑。她的怀疑并非源于她在电视上看到的东西，并非源于那些有吸引力、抽烟、酗酒、看色情网站的《南方公园》电影粉丝的同伴压力。不，她的怀疑始于教会营地。她在那里待了六周，参加一个名为“门徒训练”的项目，该项目把她和五个她以前从未见过的女孩送进树林，进行了两周的露营、徒步旅行和划独木舟。
And we were really tight. I mean, we just did everything together. We prayed and we would sing songs together at night. And when we'd get lost, I mean, the first thing we'd do would be like, it's time to pray. And when we got to Lake Superior at midnight, we were like, it's time to pray. We were just really-- I mean, it was a wonderful experience. I had a lot of fun.
我们真的很亲密。我的意思是，我们什么都一起做。我们祷告，晚上一起唱歌。当我们迷路时，我的意思是，我们做的第一件事就是，是时候祷告了。当我们午夜到达苏必利尔湖时，我们就像，是时候祷告了。我们真的很——我的意思是，那是一次美妙的经历。我玩得很开心。
And if you had to describe your feelings about God during those first two weeks, how would you describe Him?
如果你必须描述你在头两周对上帝的感受，你会如何描述他？
He was incredibly real. I felt like He was there. That was the only way I could describe it, is that He was really there for me.
他非常真实。我觉得他在那里。我唯一能描述的方式就是，他真的在那里为我。
After two weeks, Arden and her five new friends came in from the woods to rejoin the rest of the camp.
两周后，阿登和她的五个新朋友从树林里出来，重新加入营地的其他人。
My friends suddenly changed, like who I'd thought they were-- they suddenly became different. And I don't think-- I think it was just that I hadn't seen them with other people besides our group. And they were-- they would-- it all became-- you know, there was the popular one, and then there was the really helpful one, and there was the boy chaser. I mean, it was just like, I didn't know how to handle it. I was still hoping to have that intimate friendship among the five of us. And I thought I was going to die. I just couldn't take it. And then I sort of dropped into my spiritual low. And so I started having trouble praying. I didn't want to pray. And I was starting go, well, you know, what's up with this? What is real? If I can't even-- when I feel like God's there, and then I suddenly feel like He's not, where is He this whole time? You know? So that's when I really started to question. And I had all these doubts and I felt like God wasn't anywhere near me at all and He didn't care.
我的朋友们突然变了，就像我以为她们是谁——她们突然变得不一样了。我不认为——我认为只是因为我没有在我们的群体之外看到过她们与其他人在一起。她们是——她们会——这一切都变成了——你知道，有受欢迎的那一个，有非常乐于助人的那一个，还有追逐男孩的那一个。我的意思是，这就像，我不知道该怎么处理。我仍然希望我们五个之间能有那种亲密的友谊。我觉得我要死了。我简直受不了。然后我陷入了灵性的低谷。所以我开始在祷告上遇到麻烦。我不想祷告。我开始问，好吧，你知道，这是怎么回事？什么是真实的？如果我甚至不能——当我感觉到上帝在那里，然后我突然觉得他不在时，他一直都在哪？你知道吗？所以那是真正开始质疑的时候。我有所有的怀疑，我觉得上帝根本不在我身边，他也不关心。
One of the traditions in Christianity is that great faith often comes only after great doubt. The New Testament is filled with one story after another like this. Even Jesus grapples with his conscience in the desert before he begins his ministry. He prays again in Gethsemane. And listening to Arden, I begin to wonder if all new believers have to go through that trial in the desert themselves if they're going to arrive at a mature faith. This is what Dan and a number of the parents believe will keep Christianity as part of these teenagers' lives as they grow older. But it is enormously difficult to go through this kind of doubt. It makes Arden unhappy. She says she does not want another big spiritual moment, feeling close to God, like she had in the woods.
基督教的传统之一是，伟大的信仰往往只在伟大的怀疑之后才会到来。新约充满了这样一个接一个的故事。即使是耶稣在开始他的侍奉之前，也在沙漠中与良心搏斗。他在客西马尼园再次祷告。听着阿登的话，我开始想，如果所有新信徒想要获得成熟的信仰，是否都必须亲自经历沙漠中的那种试炼。这就是丹和一些父母认为可以让基督教随着这些青少年成长而继续成为他们生活一部分的原因。但经历这种怀疑是非常困难的。这让阿登不开心。她说她不想要另一个重大的属灵时刻，感觉像她在树林里那样亲近上帝。
I don't trust that anymore. I don't trust, you know, just your emotions, and where they may take you.
我不再相信那个了。我不相信，你知道，仅仅你的情绪，以及它们可能带你走向哪里。
And at the same time, she knows that without a pure leap of faith, she's nowhere.
与此同时，她知道没有纯粹的信心之跃，她就一无所有。
That's the thing that worries me the most, is that I may never find what I'm looking for. I may never find out who God is. And that worries me. Like sometimes I think, oh my gosh, you know, because I don't know where I would be. I don't know. I'd have to start all over again.
这是最让我担心的事情，是我可能永远找不到我在寻找的东西。我可能永远找不到上帝是谁。这让我很担心。有时候我想，天哪，你知道，因为我不知道我会去哪里。我不知道。我得从头再来。
Abraham our father answered his Hineni when the Lord commanded him to offer up his son. He took the wood and fire and journeyed to Moriah, and there he built an altar to complete what he'd begun.
我们的祖先亚伯拉罕在主命令他献出儿子时回答了“我在”。他带着木柴和火，前往摩利亚山，在那里他建造了一座祭坛以完成他开始的事业。
Pastor Kenny actually broke into song during his sermon on Thursday. The subject of the sermon was how the Lord calls certain people to serve him, and how when he does, they usually do not want to go. We hear the story of Abraham being called to slay Isaac, of Moses being ordered to go to Pharaoh. Kenny talks from the heart about the moment he felt he was called to preach. And then he asks all of us to look into our own hearts. Has God been speaking to us during our week in West Virginia?
肯尼牧师在周四的布道中竟然唱了起来。布道的主题是主如何呼召特定的人来侍奉他，以及当他这样做时，他们通常不想去。我们听到了亚伯拉罕被呼召去杀以撒，摩西被命令去见法老的故事。肯尼发自内心地谈到了他感到自己被呼召去布道的那一刻。然后他让我们所有人审视自己的内心。我们在西弗吉尼亚州的这一周，上帝有没有在对我们说话？
Maybe God is speaking to you. That you want to be a missionary. Now over here under my Bible, I've got a legal pad. And if you think that God is calling you to serve Him, maybe that's what God wants you to do. I'm just going to leave this pad out here and I want you to just come put your name on it. I'm not going to sell your name to any list. I'm not going to turn it in to Mission to the World. This is between-- I think you need to do that. You need to make that commitment, if God is calling you.
也许上帝正在对你说话。你想成为一名宣教士。在我圣经下面这儿，我有一本便签纸。如果你认为上帝在呼召你侍奉他，也许这就是上帝希望你做的事。我只是把这张纸放在这儿，我希望你们能过来写上名字。我不会把你们的名字卖给任何名单。我也不会把它交给“使命世界”。这是你们和——我认为你们需要做那个。如果上帝在呼召你，你需要做出那个承诺。
After the service ends, a few people mill around. The Chicago teenagers head off to the cabins, except for Joel, who walks over to the legal pad, picks it up, and writes his name. I catch up with him a few minutes later.
礼拜结束后，一些人在周围徘徊。芝加哥的青少年们前往小屋，除了乔尔，他走向便签纸，拿起笔，写下了他的名字。几分钟后我追上了他。
So I saw what you just did.
所以我看到了你刚才做的。
Yeah, I signed the list. It was-- for me-- to me-- it was the most powerful sermon I've ever heard.
是的，我在名单上签名了。对于我来说——对我来说——这是我听过的最有力的布道。
Joel tells me he now knows what he wants to do with his life. Although parts of his faith clearly still chafe at him, although he's always saying how hard it is for him to talk to people, although he still has a long way to go before he's actually at ease in the bigger secular world, he's the one member of the youth group who decided that he wants to head out into that world, as a missionary teaching in another country.
乔尔告诉我，他现在知道了他想用自己的余生做什么。尽管他信仰的某些部分显然仍然让他感到不舒服，尽管他总是说和人交谈有多难，尽管他在真正自在地融入更广阔的世俗世界之前还有很长的路要走，但他还是青年团契中唯一一个决定想进入那个世界，作为一个去另一个国家教书的宣教士的成员。
When Kenny was praying, I was just like, man, what have you been thinking all these years? No, I'm not going to be a professional soccer player. That's totally out now.
当肯尼祷告时，我心里想，伙计，这些年来你都在想些什么？不，我不会成为职业足球运动员了。那现在完全不行了。
Is that what you thought up until that point?
在那之前你是这么想的吗？
Yeah, it is.
是的，确实。
Given how restrictive-- I hope you don't take this the wrong way-- but given how restrictive your family is, I can see why you might jump at a chance to go overseas and get away.
鉴于——我希望你别误会——鉴于你的家庭限制这么多，我能理解你为什么想抓住机会去海外逃离。
Yeah, I mean, some of the rules I can understand why. I accept it because it's a good idea. But it is getting kind of restrictive now that I'm getting older.
是的，我的意思是，有些规则我能理解为什么。我接受它们，因为它们是个好主意。但随着年龄增长，现在确实变得有点限制性了。
Act Seven, Made to Stumble Because of Me. All week I kept running into those guys who wanted to be on the radio, Matt and Eric. And on the last morning in West Virginia, I see Eric out by his car. The night before, he had driven some kids from his VBS back home after dinner. Eric's group was running this huge vacation Bible school at a place called Windmill Park in a tough section of Fairmont, West Virginia. Eric had gotten close to a lot of the kids.
第七幕，因为我而绊倒。整个星期我都在遇到那些想上电台的家伙，马特和埃里克。在西弗吉尼亚州的最后一个早上，我看到埃里克在他车旁。前一天晚上，他晚饭后开车送一些参加VBS的孩子回家。埃里克的团队在西弗吉尼亚州费尔蒙特一个艰难的区域进行着大型度假圣经学校。埃里克和很多孩子变得很亲近。
Yeah, it was really hard last night, taking them home. Some car was coming too close and they're like, it's a drive-by! And they're ducking under and they were scared. One of the kids left his bike at the park and he was all afraid that it was stolen. And stuff like that. And while we were pulling in there, they were like, keep your head low because there's bullets around here, and stuff like that. It's just really hard to think of these little first through fourth graders having to deal with this stuff every day. And we gave out prizes on our last day and a kid had to run home so that he could get the prizes to his house without having them taken from him. So it's rough. I mean, that's why I think, I'm almost-- I was almost like kind of down on the whole idea of VBS, because it's like you invest in these kids for a week, and they get close, and relationships are built. And then it's cut off. So I just felt like emotionally, it was just too hard on them. And last night I was really struggling with that whole idea.
是的，昨晚送他们回家真的很艰难。有辆车靠得太近，他们就说，是拍车门啊！他们躲在下面，他们很害怕。其中一个孩子把自行车留在了公园，他很担心被偷。之类的事。当我们开进去的时候，他们说，把头压低，因为这附近有子弹什么的。想到这些一年级到四年级的小孩子每天都要处理这种事，真是太难了。我们在最后一天发奖品，一个孩子必须跑回家，这样他才能在奖品被抢走之前把它们带回家。所以这很粗暴。我的意思是，这就是为什么我认为，我几乎——我对整个VBS的想法感到有点失望，因为这就像你在这一周里投资这些孩子，他们变得亲近，建立了关系。然后它就被切断了。所以我只是觉得在情感上，这对他们来说太沉重了。昨晚我真的在纠结整个想法。
That's interesting. Earlier in the week, we were talking about if you guys were going to change, and in the end, you did see something you hadn't seen before.
那很有趣。在一周早些时候，我们谈论过你们是否会改变，最后，你们确实看到了之前没看到的东西。
Definitely. I mean, definitely. Because that was really hard. I was very broken up by the thought of whether it's right to do these one-week VBSs. And invest in this kids just to then leave them.
当然。我的意思是，当然。因为那真的很难。一想到做这些为期一周的VBS是否正确，我就感到很受伤。投资这些孩子只是为了然后离开他们。
At the end of their week, the Chicagoans are feeling proud of how far they've come-- with the vacation Bible school, with Angie and Paula and Crystal, who they invited to dinner out at the campsite on the last night. People promise to write to each other. When we ask Crystal which parts of the Bible did she think that she would be reading, now that Carol had pointed out some sections to her, she can't remember which sections Carol had said. She says she doesn't really read anything on her own.
在一周结束时，芝加哥队为他们取得的进步感到自豪——度假圣经学校，还有安吉、宝拉和克里斯托，她们被邀请在最后一晚去营地吃饭。大家承诺互相写信。当我们问克里斯托，既然卡罗尔指出了其中的一些章节，她认为她会读圣经的哪些部分时，她记不起卡罗尔说的是哪些部分了。她说她自己其实什么都不读。
At services that last night, some kids from the East Coast get up to perform a song. They're in a band called Iris and the song is about one of the unique burdens of being a teenager and a Christian.
在最后一晚的礼拜上，一些东海岸的孩子上台表演了一首歌。他们在一个名为“Iris”的乐队里，这首歌是关于作为青少年和基督徒的独特负担之一。
So, hopefully, I'd like to encourage you all to not let it stop here, but when you go back, if you have friends or family that you can witness to, continue to share the love of Christ with people.
所以，我希望能鼓励你们所有人不要让它止步于此，当你们回去时，如果你有可以作见证的朋友或家人，继续与人们分享基督的爱。
[SINGING] Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Are you so self-assured in everything you confide? Are my beliefs so absurd? I would not try to hide. I'm not trying to push you, but I hate to see you like this. I love you too much to let you die in ignorance. You're on a ledge and the ground beneath is breaking. You try to swim, you're sinking slow but surely grab his hands. Hey, friend, I won't have your blood upon my hands. Hey friend, what can I do to make you understand? To make you understand?
[演唱] 是的，是的，是的，是的。是的，是的，是的，是的。你在你所信任的一切中都如此自信吗？我的信仰如此荒谬吗？我不会试图隐藏。我不是要逼你，但我讨厌看到你这样。我爱你太深，不能让你死于无知。你站在悬崖边，下面的地正在破碎。你试着游泳，你正在慢慢下沉但肯定会抓住他的手。嘿，朋友，我不会让你的血沾在我的手上。嘿朋友，我能做什么让你明白？让你明白？
As for whether the Chicago kids are up to the task of actually proselytizing their non-Christian friends, they do not seem eager or ready. It's one thing to befriend strangers in another state. It's another kind of commitment to their faith to try it at home. It's a sacrifice. But on the long drive home, Joel, the future missionary, says he doesn't think it'll happen with the group.
至于芝加哥的孩子们是否有能力真正去向非基督徒朋友传教，他们似乎并不渴望或准备好。与外州的陌生人交友是一回事，尝试在家里传教是另一种对信仰的承诺。这是一种牺牲。但在回家的漫长车程中，未来的宣教士乔尔说，他不认为这会在这个小组中发生。
Either the people won't want to come, or at least as far as I'm concerned, I'm too nervous to ask them. And I already-- and I also-- in the case of most of my non-Christian friends, I already know what their answer would be. They don't-- they're fine with me being Christian. But they don't have any interest in it themselves, at least not at this point.
要么人们不想来，或者就我而言，我太紧张不敢问他们。而且我已经——而且我还——就我大多数非基督徒朋友而言，我已经知道他们的答案会是什么了。他们不介意我是基督徒。但他们自己没有任何兴趣，至少目前还没有。
In the four months since the trip, only one member of the group has brought a non-Christian friend to youth group. As for contact with Crystal and Paula and Angie, an adult leader wrote a letter to Angie, and sent a Bible that they all signed. There hasn't been a lot more. And maybe this lack of proselytizing energy is not such a bad thing. If Dan is going to stick to his goal from the trip, helping the kids examine what they believe, the real tests of faith for most people are not usually in interactions with people hundreds of miles away, or with people they're trying to convert. Real tests of faith happen with the people closest to you, with parents and friends. It was a bunch of Christians who made Arden question her faith. It's a desire to kiss a nice Christian girl that made Joel question his. Those questions are likely to continue.
自那次旅行以来的四个月里，小组中只有一名成员带过非基督徒朋友参加青年团契。至于与克里斯托、宝拉和安吉的联系，一位成年领袖给安吉写了一封信，并寄去了一本他们都签名的圣经。并没有更多的联系。也许这种缺乏传教活力的事情并不是一件坏事。如果丹要坚持他旅行的目标，帮助孩子们审视他们所相信的东西，那么大多数人信仰的真正考验通常不在于与数百英里外的人互动，也不在于与他们试图改造的人互动。信仰的真正考验发生在与你最亲近的人身上，与父母和朋友。正是这群基督徒让阿登质疑她的信仰。是想要亲吻一个可爱的基督徒女孩让乔尔质疑他的。这些问题很可能会持续下去。
Well, our program was produced and reported today by Susan Burton and myself, with help from Alex Blumberg, Nancy Updike, Blue Chevigny, Starlee Kine, and Todd Bachmann. Julie Snyder was our editor on the story.
好的，我们的节目今天由苏珊·伯顿和我自己制作和报道，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、南希·厄普代克、布鲁·切维尼、斯塔莉·凯恩和托德·巴赫曼提供了帮助。朱莉·斯奈德是我们故事的编辑。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
To buy a cassette of this or any of our programs, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. And if you're still somehow mulling over that perfect Christmas gift, even today, our double CD, Lies, Sissies, and Fiascoes, The Best of This American Life, is available at our website, at www.thislife.org. At the site you can also listen to our program for free, and listen to more music from the Christian rock band, Iris. Thanks to Elizabeth Meister who runs the site.
要购买此节目或我们任何节目的磁带，请致电我们在芝加哥的WBEZ，电话312-832-3380。如果你今天还在为那个完美的圣诞礼物犹豫不决，我们的双CD《谎言、胆小鬼和惨败，美国生活的精华》可以在我们的网站上买到，网址是www.thislife.org。在网站上，你也可以免费收听我们的节目，并收听更多来自基督教摇滚乐队Iris的音乐。感谢管理网站的伊丽莎白·迈斯特。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who taunts me-- taunts me!-- all the time.
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他一直嘲笑我——嘲笑我！——一直。
Oh, come on, you know you want it.
噢，得了吧，你知道你想要这个。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多关于这个美国生活的故事。
And I'm like, no, I don't.
我说，不，我才不。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。